pour tenter de diluer l'injustice de
votre réforme vous avez annoncé aux
Français à longueur de plateau télé
qu'il pourrait bénéficier à minima d'une
retraite à 1200 euros vous annoncez
désormais que les 1200 euros
s'entendraient brut ce qui n'est pas
sans causer une vraie différence dans le
portefeuille des ménages nous vous avons
demandé à plusieurs reprises combien de
personnes pourront véritablement
bénéficier des 1200 euros vous refusez
de répondre précisément oui vous mentez
vous dissimulez la vérité c'est celle
qui a clairement expliqué l'économiste
Michael Zemmour il n'y aura pas de
pension minimale garantie à 1200 euros y
compris pour les carrières complètes la
réalité c'est celle décrite par les
économistes de l'Institut des politiques
publiques moins de 10% des nouveaux
retraités sont potentiellement concernés
par l'augmentation maximale de 100 euros
permettant d'approcher les 1200 euros le
président de la République l'a dit je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure
de 85% du SMIC c'est pour une carrière
complète au niveau du SMIC aujourd'hui
42 annuités demain 43 annuités et c'est
cet objectif que nous poursuivons de
garantir ce niveau minimum de pension à
85% du SMIC pour une carrière complète
vous me dites madame la députée combien
de personnes se lave représenter je l'ai
dit c'est un retraité sur 4 qui
bénéficiera d'une revalorisation de
pension et un million 100000 retraités
sur les 17 millions de retraités actuels
qui vont bénéficier d'une revalorisation
aussi sur le million 800 000 retraités
actuels un million et 100000 retraités
actuels qui vont avoir une
revalorisation de leur pension 50%
d'entre eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce que je tenais apporter une réponse
précise à sa question
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre